by the way I predicted you would propose
the last time I was with you and sure
enough you did when is the wedding I
want dates or any of that stuff will
Pete Davidson be your best man I believe
he will be I think my side is gonna is
gonna be
um and R is gonna be an army A few I
have I have so many close and best
friends that have been with me for all
these years but yeah I think Pete's
absolutely gonna be standing there with
me and we we should just like him just
for commentary anyway oh it's funny what
was I was reading about you talk about
bet you know I don't have like best
friends like you do I mean and and I'm
envious of this because like you and
Pete went to see Dave Chappelle
Chappelle says oh [ __ ] my mom's birthday
is uh happening I forgot all about it
Chappelle takes you guys over to his
mom's birthday party you guys all party
with his mom and everyone's smoking weed
even the mom and then didn't you and and
Pete get in a car and go on a road trip
I mean it's it's a bromance with this
guy it's unbelievable right it is it is
it is I was blessed like he came into my
life we both came into each other's life
at the right time and what
and what came with Kim Kardashian this
this is even a bigger thing this sounds
like so much fun to me yeah yeah I'm so
happy for him yeah I actually have I
actually have a big regret
the short version is I was like I was
like you know we rented out of theater
we Megan Kim he went to see a movie
um and I was like vouching for this
movie so hard I was like it's gonna be
the best movie you've ever seen I kept
like I kept like leaning over like even
like as the previews were starting I was
like just just dude I can't wait I can't
wait for you guys to watch and like dude
we got 10 minutes into the movie you
ever just you ever just have that moment
where you're like
we shouldn't be here like this now even
that sounds like great hijinks you and
Pete rent a a theater for your women so
you guys can see the movie on your own
and of course you get blamed for the
shitty movie but uh no I was just I it
was more like we were all just laughing
at how like I get very kiddish sometimes
I'm always like ah like I guess when I'm
excited I get excited and um yeah but
let me ask you this when the world is
[ __ ] on you and you feel like [ __ ]
you know all I'm trying to do is
entertain people and people in your life
you need to describe they're there for
you which I I think is great you do need
that are you there for Pete when people
are [ __ ] on him when Kanye's
involved I got thrown in that too oddly
enough but at the end of the day man
we're we're young men trying to find our
place in the world and figuring it out
and it doesn't really help when you got
a million voices you know ripping you
apart or telling you're doing this wrong
or this one it's just like you know
we're all just figuring it out man this
is life
and we love everybody man we we have so
much love you know we it's it's it's
almost like if we need to be the vessels
for people's anger then you know so be
it that must be while we're here you
know but I do hope that
they can feel our spirit and see that
you know that we love you though